hallo mein name ist meine damen und
herren wir sehen es bereitete
eingeblendet sie reagieren heute mal
wieder zusammen auf dem feld
mit luca das hier ist der erste ebay
fell und zwar es sollte eine lavalampe
abgebildet steht allerdings darunter
eine lavalampe unterhaltungsliteratur
die lava lampe ist definitiv
unterhaltungsliteratur das nächste bild
das judo für mich ausgesucht hat ist
eine handy halterung für 88 euro sieht
aber so aus dass saugnapf geklebt
einfach an der windschutzscheibe vom
auto und daran ist das handy mit zwei
bändern befestigt also es ist eigentlich
keine so beschissene idee du halt auch
nicht ganz legal die verkauft jemand
seine neue tommy tommy holger wer kennt
es nicht
tommy holger tommy holger herrenjacke
bomba stewart größe m navy für 100 euro
ich glaube er meinte dieses angebot
eigentlich ernst aber er hat dann
irgendwie über autokorrektur das
verpackt und dann wurde hilfiger zur
holger gemacht oder es ist halt einfach
wirklich eine jacke von tommy holger als
nächstes haben wir hier einen gaming
stuhl für anfänger das sind diese
richtigen schulklassen stühle ich weiß
nicht was ihr in eurer schule für stühle
habt das könnte aber gerne und in die
kommentare schreiben wie wollt ihr
schreiben was man studie habt aber als
ich noch zur schule gegangen sein die
stühle wirklich genau so aus und ich das
ding war auch hier hatten die meisten
fächer im oberstufen trakt von unserem
gymnasium allerdings hatten wir einige
fächer auch dort wo normalerweise die
fünft bis siebtklässler unterricht haben
und da waren halt die gleichen stühle
die wir sollen sie mal hatten nur halt
in ca halb so groß und ich bin jetzt
echt kein klein gewachsener mensch und
von daher ja saß dann schon mal so aus
als sich darauf saß machen allerdings
direkt weiter mit dem nächsten ebay
kleinanzeigen feld und zwar ist dieser
leider nicht mit einem foto versehen
sondern entsteht dort einfach nur scheiß
peugeot 106 kaputt zu verschenken
wieso zu verschenken das auto hat einen
motorschaden weil die stadt öl eine
mischung aus wasser magie und spülmittel
eingefüllt und dann im stand vollgas
gegeben habe papiere sind dabei
unterschiede dach geht noch auf ja
das wichtigste ist ja eh dass das
schiebedach aufgeht als nächstes
verkaufte jemand seinen bus weicher dino
für kinder ab drei jahren geeignet wer
kennt ihn nicht den dynamos august u
wert bestimmt ein geiler us-trio foto
logo channel die als ob ich habe
letztens wirklich meine youtube
statistiken geschaut und 60 prozent die
meine videos anschauen sind gar nicht
abonnent leute klickten die wiederwahl
boni hat was denn los mit euch jetzt
nächstes hatte jemand in die bay
gestellt verkauf fuß umarmung umarmt
mich ich fühle mich allen fuß umarmungen
nur diesen monat im sonder sale google
übersetzer wen du wollen dann ich machen
fuß haare weg nur wenn mehr geld geben
versand nicht gut sind solche minen
götter die sowas in ebay stellt
gelegenheit dem halter bmw e36
individual 32 8 m3 h selten cdn war nur
noch cd dahinter schreiben also das hier
ist der dürren halter vor allem auch in
der kategorie ersatz und reparatur teile
ich sehen dürfen auch als ersatz und
reparatur thailand hier verkauft jemand
sein vodafone will das gerät ist ob
zustand ist die sonne scheiße einfallen
lässt
der bmw ist super nur für mich zu
schnell 8000 euro bin ich ganz ehrlich
es ist normales legitimes angebot die
person sagt einfach dass das auto was
sie jetzt hat gerade hat also dieser 1er
bmw ihm einfach zu schnell ist und er
deswegen verkaufen möchte dich völlig in
ordnung kaffeemaschine latte macchiato
cappuccino
eigentlich heißt es latte macchiato er
schreibt allerdings latte macchiato wir
verkaufen unsere kaffeemaschine latte
macchiato café latte funktioniert eine
färberei der hat viele funktionen man
kann noch einen kaffee bei mir trinken
ausprobieren bei weitere frage bitte
anrufen ist eigentlich auch ein
vernünftiges angebot er weiß
wahrscheinlich einfach nicht wie die
latte macchiato geschrieben wird als
nächstes verkaufte jemand ein kinderbuch
und zwar sultan moschee das ist sultan
moschee ebay kleinanzeigen videos
bestehenden höher da hab ich das ich
klatschen durch mein zimmer lauf und
lache das nächste ebay angebot ist ein
chihuahua sucht süße dame zum beglücken
decken kondomen und richtige playboy
dieser chihuahua als euch übrigens fragt
wo ich diese ganzen ebay kleinanzeigen
fels finde ich habe euch mal und in die
beschreibung einen link gepackt von
einer instagram seite wo wirklich jeden
tag ebay fails gepostet werden und
direkt darunter ist auch noch meinen
instagram ich heiße laserdrucker da
könnt ihr mir gern auch mal folgen
machen allerdings weiter mit dem
nächsten fehler und zwar einem bonbon
automat der ist allerdings leider leer
verkaufte sie da kannst du jedes
geldstück rein machen und den kommt der
bonbon kommt den raus ahk da bult aus
holz verkauft hier jemand der kommt aus
4 0 822 mettmann die artist pflanzen und
in der beschreibung steht verkaufe
katapult ausholt schief sehr weit und
wieder das nächste angebot ist denke ich
ziemlich gut für mich geeignet und zwar
ein bad für bartlosen verkaufe hier
einen gut erhaltenen bat der bart ist
wachstum aus 2018 wurde nur einmal
getragen und regelmäßig gewaschen sehr
schön dass er noch einmal getragen wurde
dieser bart ist ein absolutes
naturprodukte ohne zusatzstoffe oder
spezielle hilfsmittel gezogen eignet
sich auch wunderbar als schamhaar ersatz
werde ich direkt kaufen als erstes
verkauft ihr jemand durex kondome für
fünf euro verhandelbar und in der
beschreibung steht sechs stücken neue
haltbar bis märz 2019 also sind auch
schon abgelaufen wenn sie nicht gesehen
ziemlich
stoßen nun haben wir hier wirklich ein
angebot auf ebay wo ich mir wichtig
denke hey solch preislich und luxuriöse
weg den gegenstände würde ich eigentlich
nicht bei ebay verkaufen
haselnüsse meine damen und herren die
version verkauft haselnüsse für zwei
euro und in der beschreibung steht
freien säuberlich von ferrero küsschen
raus gülle
das alter haselnüssen mit bisschen
spucke noch dran das nächste produkt das
ihr verkauft wird ist ein camping wc
wartungsfrei so sieht's aus ist aber
eigentlich keine beschissene idee bzw
wenn man packen muss dann ist das schon
eine beschissene idee wir machen auf
jeden fall direkt weiter mit einem
waschechten sammlerstück hier auf ebay
und zwar diese nudel packung beinhaltet
eigentlich nur fossile jedoch ist in der
geschlossenen packung eine muschel
nudeln zu führen
da ist ein echtes einzelstück für jeden
sammler also wirklich freunde
falls jemand von euch diese einzigartige
muschel nudel werden möchte gibt es nun
zu kaufen auf ebay als nächstes
verkaufte jemand seine erni spiel
telefon der heißt eigentlich er nie das
nächste die bei angebot finde ich
ziemlich wüst und zwar wichtig auch
selbst eigentlich gern zu schnappen und
zwar ist es einen golden retriever wird
allerdings bietet als golden retriever
also ein goldener roter fluss und mal
wieder klatsche ich einfach nur und ihr
verkauft jemand eine party gitarre
ermäßigt zu autos erst einmal eine rumpf
flasche unterhalt seiner hand daran aber
da unten drunter steht auf jeden fall
nagelneue party gitarre schon
eingespielt und gestimmt perfekt für
jeden auftritt geil alter kann es auf
meiner hochzeit spielen gaming sessel
ist das nächste angebot das hier
reingestellt wurde auf ibm der gaming
setzen sieht allerdings so aus bin ich
auch eigentlich wieder ganz ehrlich ist
eigentlich nice weil wenn man wirklich
zockt und man ist im spiel und dann dann
hier verkauft jemand einen ford leid
epischen sieg das
für mich auch interessant der nächste
beitrag den ich euch jetzt zeigen werde
ist kein angebot also nichts was man
ihnen die kaufen kann sondern es ist
einfach ein
ja
vogel gefunden und wollte dessen posten
auf ebay wache allerdings nun wieder
weiter mit einem richtigen ebay angebot
und zwar verkaufte jemand seine power
bank geht ein bahn frei als nächstes
verkauft sich jemand auf ebay eine
ohrfeige zum abholen kostenlos eine
ohrfeige abholen da die nachfrage hoch
ist bitte ich um termine zu guter letzt
schauen wir uns nur noch einen ebay
kleinanzeigen angebot aus möhringen an
und zwar ein aufsitzrasenmäher gebraucht
guter zustand
es ist ein schaf wo man sich drauf
setzen kann dank modernster technologie
einfach mit wasser betanken
wer kommt auf so eine scheiße anderer
stelle mich das heutige video ist
allerdings auch beenden meiner lieben
zuschauer wenn euch diese dritte folge
ebay kleinanzeigen fans mit luca
gefallen hat und das gerne einen daumen
hoch bei diesem video jedoch schreibt
mir und in die kommentare ob ich auch
nächste woche einen vierten teil
hochladen soll wie bereits gesagt falls
ihr noch kein abonnent von meinem kanal
sei dann würde ich mich sehr freuen wenn
ihr unter dem abonnieren klicken würde
und wenn ihr schon ein endzeit dann auf
die glocke
denn dann bekommt ihr direkt eine
benachrichtigung sobald ich ein neues
video hochladen mensch ist das geil
[Musik]